I wish I had never done the Zyto scan. So this is a person who did a Zyto scan at another
clinicians office or office. But a Zyto scan is one of those little instruments where you put
your hand on this scanner and then in five minutes it tells you everything that's wrong with you.
Now I say that a little facetiously because I mean that a little facetiously. I'm not the biggest
fan of Zyto scans. So let's finish the question. The pesticide numbers came back shockingly high.
Our home has all hardwood floors, three in-home air purifiers, all-house water filtration system,
all-nod toxic cleaning and cosmetic products. The only explanation of the scanner, I think the person
who did the scanning and was that we live near a park. Even though my husband did not show
the same results only me. And pesticides can travel up to two miles. I've inclined to take this
with a grain of salt. Of course they're the products that this person recommended. Some of them are
already on and some I would not touch with the 10th would pull any thoughts. Dr. C plus the
live numbers were high. So number one I think Zyto scans are fine to give you an idea that you might
something might be going on. But I would never ever, ever, nor do they think that it's appropriate
to give a person a diagnosis based upon a Zyto scan. Then why would you do it?
Yeah, I don't know. Good question. So maybe as an indicator that let's say if you did a Zyto scan
and it came back super high and pesticides, then maybe that would spark me to do
a toxicity. You're a test. And that's what I would use as my data. So remember any test that's
out there, whether it be a physical exam, a neurological exam, a CT scan or a PET scan or a regular
blood test. All these things give you clues. Same thing with a Zyto scan. It gives you clues.
That's all it gives you. You cannot diagnose off a Zyto scan. Honestly, I think it's not only
inappropriate. I think it's borderline male practice. I just don't think it's that accurate.
So the second thing is if it is accurate, it's picking up frequencies. So if you picked up the
frequency of a pesticide, does that mean you have that pesticide? No, it doesn't. So I'm not a fan.
So I would do it and I would be inclined as well to take this with a great assault. The only reason
again why I would do it is maybe in a screening setting to see if I should do further testing.
You do not diagnose off a Zyto scan. Having positive pesticides,
quote, unquote, show up on your Zyto scan, does not mean you have pesticides in your body.
Having positive lines show up on a Zyto scan, does not mean you have lime in your body.
So why would you do it? I don't know. So I would just toss it myself. Sorry.